you were one of the first guys kind of
early rumored to be in this movie
then you're announced and then you kind
of went off the grid where'd you go what
happens just kind of get away so you
didn't have to answer phone calls all
that jazz no I was just working I mean I
it's not like I arrived anywhere when it
was announced it just kind of came out
and I had really nothing to do with it
to me but you know just working until
until now I guess I didn't really go
anywhere kylo Ren comes out in that
first teaser trailer that we got a year
ago and the dudes are ready iconic it's
crazy like that doesn't happen often to
where the the lightsaber comes out that
everyone's talking about the lightsaber
and now he is like a memorable villain
did you expect that to come even before
the movie came out oh no no I didn't
know how all of this was gonna roll out
I guess and you know before it started
but I guess it's a good thing you know
that people something about it people
respond to I would assume that this
character is very different from any
other roles that you've played can you
give me a little bit about what makes
them different from other characters
that you've portrayed I mean what other
than the obvious it's you know a long
time ago in a galaxy far away right you
know the world is so just you know just
set and in that that's that's kind of a
lot of it but in a ways it's I don't
know it's hard for me to say but in the
working on I tried to treat it like
anything else I guess I want to play one
game with you if that's all right okay
but it's just it's just a facial
recognition thing I just want you don't
have to say a thing I just want to see
how you react when I say a word okay all
right light side dark side this is way
better
who knows anything Darth Plagueis
rebellion all right before I let you go
get something from Fandango and this is
for you for a very specialized Star Wars
movie card for you and please go ahead
and hope that I hope you enjoy it and if
you can see ya over there it's the the
force awakens specialized card so enjoy
that please sir and thank you so much
and thank you very much I cannot wait
for this movie I'm excited for you to
see
[Music]
you